hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his essay on truth and lying in an
extra moral sense
Nietzsche begins by talking about the
human intellect and this is a faculty
that throughout the history of
philosophy up until Nietzsche's time and
and really even still today in in most
philosophical traditions he has been
understood as not only being the highest
faculty in human beings but as our means
of access to modes of knowledge or even
of life that are both typically human in
a certain way but also go beyond the
human the intellect is understood is
sort of opening up the universe to us in
a way that's not possible for non
rational animals animals that lack and
intellect or these sorts of faculties
and Nietzsche begins by in effect
deflating the intellect he's got this
interesting you know story here that
he's telling he says in some remote
corner of the universe that is poured
out in countless flickering solar
systems there was once a star on which
clever animals invented knowledge this
that was the most arrogant in the most
untruthful moment in world history yet
indeed only a moment after nature taken
a few breaths the star froze over and
the clever animals he had to die and
then he goes in and he says someone
could invent such a fable this is a
fable for him and still not have
Illustrated adequately how pitiful how
shadowy and fleeting how purposeless and
arbitrary the human intellect appears in
nature so there's the story that the
intellect tells itself and that we tell
ourselves about the intellect and then
there's the reality of the intellect
within nature and notice what what
Nietzsche says there's really two sort
of lines of complaint or a denigration
going on here one is about it's its own
lack of capacities it's shadowy right it
is it is not what it appears to be and
the other has to do with purpose with
having a function a real function and
and Nietzsche does think the intellect
has a function but it's not what we
pretend that it is it's not the story
again that we we tell ourselves so he
goes on and he says if we want to
compare ourselves to other kinds of
being you know the intellect has no
further mission leading beyond human
life he says it's utterly human only its
owner and producer takes it with such
pathos as if the whole world hinged upon
it if we could communicate with the mat
or any other animal indeed it would say
that its faculties are just as important
and its view of the world is just as
central he talks about it feels itself
the flying center of the world so this
means that the intellect is really in a
kind of self delusion about its own
importance and about the importance of
the animal the human being that bears
that Faculty so what is the function of
the intellect I just mentioned that
Nietzsche thinks that its purpose is
ultimately to serve human life not to go
beyond the realm of life but just to
conduce to two things we we are the
animals that have developed in such a
way as we have this this this skill or
this faculty or this capacity that the
others lack for thinking things out or
they don't they don't have it developed
to the same extent for taking the world
and representing it inside of our heads
and tinkering around with it and even
applying it to our own selves thinking
about why we do the things we do why we
say the things we say why we feel the
way that we do we develop that according
to Nietzsche not so that we can grasp
truth itself to begin with for Nietzsche
truth itself is kind of a figment of our
imagination and our language but he says
it quite clearly here that the
intellects role is not primarily
apprehending truth the intellects role
is to serve life to
help us live so he talks about it here
he says in reality this faculty is given
only as help to the most unfortunate
most delicate and most perishable
creature and if you think about how
that's the case you know we are the
creature that has the big old brain that
requires that babies have to be brought
up and they're helpless for a much much
longer time the baby has to eventually
develop intellectually right and and we
lack many of the instincts that other
animals do that just sort of kick in and
get them where they need to go and have
them doing what they need to do we have
to kind of figure it all out and we
often go astray with that sort of thing
all right we're plasticity of our nature
can be a boon or an encumbrance so
there's that end of it but then even as
adults what is our intellect therefore
it's to help us this vulnerable creature
I mean look at us right we have these
nails that aren't really claws we have
these tiny little teeth you know of
course our bite is pretty toxic because
of all the bacteria that we carry in our
mouths but we can't really rely on that
we're able to do things because we apply
our intellects and that is the advantage
that we have over other creatures so he
goes on he says the intellect is a means
of preserving the individual a means of
preserving one's life of maintaining the
integrity of one's body you could say
and then he goes on and says it develops
its main powers in dis simulation and
German fierce tell'em setting something
else out in place of what really is
substituting one thing for another and
if you think about the way in which the
intellect does work that is an important
part of it you know we talk about
processes for example of abstraction
what does abstraction really it is
depending on you know what psychological
theory you have for it it's taking one
thing and having it stand in
a whole bunch of others and this is
something he talks about quite a bit in
terms of concepts and language a little
bit later on in the essay but I did want
to talk about the modes of dis
simulation that he talks about here and
we're gonna look both at the English and
the German for this just in part because
it's nice to to compare the two so he
says this art of dis simulation right
which we use as a tool both to get by in
relation to the other animals in our
environment and other people and also to
to help ourselves psychologically deal
with with life he says this art of
dissimulation reaches its peak in man
here deception flattery lying and
cheating slander false pretenses living
on borrowed glory masquerading
conventions of concealment play-acting
before others and before oneself in some
the constant fluttering about the flame
of vanity is so much the rule and the
law that almost nothing is more
incomprehensible than how an honest and
pure desire for truth could arise among
men how is it that if we look at human
beings and we see all these different
ways in which they fool other people and
try to fool the the other animals in the
world and fool themselves how did the
desire for truth arise so that that's an
interesting question
that's not one that we're gonna worry
over much about in this particular
discussion so you know he says what what
are these in in in German right he says
Tyshawn right deception flattery Schmidt
Schmidt :
right lugan and true again nice you know
thing right they're lying and cheating
then when he talks about slander that is
literally the behind the back talking
hinter Dirac and Radin represent earrin
is this false pretences dasya manborg
and a glance
Leoben dust mask mask ayrton mascara
design sorry masquerading you know
placing a mask on oneself taking on a
persona the original meaning of persona
was in fact mask right that that an
actor would put on by the way hypocrite
comes from the word for actor you know
the one who was literally before the
judges he goes out and he talks about
conventions of concealment right
conventions of concealment whoo-hoo
Linda convention conventions of hiding
things conventions for hiding things we
live by a number of conventions that
tell us how to get by in the world but
also hide the true nature's of things
from us or at least you know if we don't
want to talk about truth just what the
things are he goes on and he says
play-acting before others and oneself
right Boonen schpeel for andhra and
fours except right so this is all ways
of using the intellect using the
capacities that we have to substitute
one thing in place of another in order
to gain not truth but some sort of
advantage for life and the better the
intellect is the more facile it is in
discovering the means of persuasion and
confusion and concealment and
dissimilation so what else do we need to
say about the intellect and its role
here in this essay on truth and lying in
an extra moral sense the last thing that
we see him talking about throughout this
is that the intellect really does seem
to grasp and form concepts and even laws
of nature but Nietzsche is suspicious of
this he thinks that this is really a
kind of lying right conventionalized
sort of lying that the intellect itself
engages in so these these very laws of
nature or concepts are
themselves forms of dis simulation and
that is what the intellect does best